back to where he wants to be Benjamin
Netanyahu is now officially tasked by
Israel's president to form the next
government
I intend to be the prime minister of
everyone those who voted for me and
those who didn't this is not just for
the sake of saying I believe in this
this is what guides me and is my
responsibility as the prime minister of
Israel
outgoing prime minister yeah lapid
released a statement saying that today
is a black day for Israeli democracy and
said that all this was an effort by
Netanyahu to delay his ongoing
corruption trial Netanyahu will now have
to deal with the consequences of his own
Creation in his efforts to come back to
Power he promoted religious
ultra-nationalists they've now moved
from Fringe to political mainstream
itamar bengavere's Jewish power party
along with bezalel smartrich's religious
Zionism now the third biggest Block in
the Israeli Parliament their beliefs
range from annexing the West Bank to
expelling Palestinians deemed hostile to
the Jewish State and openly calling for
the right to Jewish prayer at the
Al-Aqsa Moss compound
they also want changes in law that would
weaken the powers of the Supreme Court
in Israel many Israelis also have
concerns about their secular way of life
due to the religious far-right and the
ultra-orthodox now having a large
presence in government
the U.S Administration has signaled its
concerns over the inclusion of members
of the far right being in government
some say it will be a challenge for
Netanyahu known for his political
Mastery well I think that he's not
really happy because now we have to run
a country when you have to run a country
you do not only think about local
politics you think about the world now
the world is not
so good for him right now for example if
Trump was the president of the United
States it would be easier for him
Netanyahu now has 28 days to form a
government but he could present it to
the Israeli knesset much earlier as
negotiations had already begun before he
was officially tossed on Sunday
from the moment Benjamin Netanyahu was
ousted from Power last year he vowed to
bring down the government and he vowed
to return as prime minister it's taken
him just over a year to achieve his goal
he is officially back and he's back with
a vengeance bringing with him the most
right-wing government in Israel's
history Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera West
Jerusalem